[Music]
deaths continue to spiral out of control
due to the oxygen crisis that the world
has termed the sickness
last year i had 20 kids in my class this
year i have 12.
do you know what your father did here
meet the chronicle what if i told you
that you could save all of us
save your wife we received a message
from the future in the future this is a
phone machine the people who sent the
message must have found a cure
do you really believe i'm going to save
the world you're all manly
you may be humanity's only chance to
finally cure
10 nine eight
seven six five
four three two
[Applause]
one
whoever sent the message we need to find
it
we are at the beginning of virginia we
can change everything
you have to trust me now this isn't that
funny
there's something bigger at play imagine
that we are all connected by the very
fabric of the universe
[Music]
[Applause]
an invisible field that bonds us
together here
me the stars we can't change anything
it's always going to play out this way
there is no other way
all connected through time about saving
the world
[Music]
you